you a complete me it was one of those  moments where I was asked if I would be  interested in playing The Joker and I I  knew five seconds later exactly how to  play it and I sat down with uh Chris and  shared my thoughts with him and they  were identical to his it's just been  stupid amounts of fun you want to know  what got these scars you know he's  incredibly he's dark he's very nasty  he's a psychopath sociopath Mass  murdering clown you know and I knew how  Chris was you know he'd already set up  the world for me I'd seen her what world  it was that I would be playing and so I  knew it was open for a fresh  interpretation and I I also instantly  kind of had something up my sleeve which  happened to be exactly what Chris was  kind of looking for